Aujourd'hui,
près de 60% de la population mondiale vit
sous des dictatures
ou des régimes autoritaires.
Ça doit nous interpeller pour réfléchir
à l'avenir de notre politique commerciale.
Voulons-nous
seulement conclure des accords de commerce
avec des pays qui sont dits
des démocraties ?
Que faisons-nous
avec des régimes autoritaires ?
Prenons l'exemple de la Chine.
Nous le voyons bien,
la Chine a une vision du monde
totalement différente de la nôtre
et nous sommes dépendants
pour autant de la Chine.
Comment voulons-nous rééquilibrer
cette dépendance ?
Comment voulons-nous aussi,
au travers de cette politique commerciale,
faire bouger les choses pour la réalité,
pour faire en sorte,
par exemple, que le travail des enfants
ne soit plus mis en place.
C’est pourquoi nous mettons en place
notamment ce que nous appelons “Import Ban”
c'est-à-dire bannir les produits
issus du travail forcé à nos frontières.
Notre politique commerciale
est donc un outil essentiel
pour défendre la démocratie,
pour se battre pour nos valeurs.
Nous le faisons aussi à travers la réforme
dite des chapitres “Développement durable”,
ces chapitres Développement durable,
ils traitent au développement durable,
mais aussi la question des droits humains,
les droits du travail.
Cette réforme des chapitres
développement durable va nous permettre
progressivement, en fait,
de fermer l'accès à notre marché intérieur
si nos partenaires ne respectent pas
leurs engagements
que nous avons permis d'avoir
dans des futurs accords de commerce.
On le voit bien
en matière de politique extérieure,
la politique commerciale joue
un levier fondamental.
Mais pour autant, sommes-nous
prêts à conclure n'importe
quel accord de commerce ? Non.
Prenons l'exemple du Mercosur.
Nous nous réjouissons que le président
Lula gagne les élections au Brésil.
C'est fondamental pour la démocratie.
Mais cet accord,
il pose encore des questions sur le fond,
sur la question du changement climatique,
mais aussi sur la concurrence déloyale
pour nos agriculteurs.
Donc, nous le voyons bien,
la politique commerciale est un enjeu
extrêmement complexe
pour lequel il nous faut continuer
de définir une voie qui ne soit pas
celle de l'ouverture délétère,
ni celle de la fermeture délétère,
mais véritablement
une politique commerciale
qui nous permette
de défendre nos intérêts, nos ambitions
et nos valeurs, nos valeurs démocrates.